The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, welcome
to the final lecture of 6046.
Today we continue our theme
of cache oblivious algorithms.
We're going to look
at two of the most
basic problems in
computer science--
searching and sorting,
a little bit of each.
And then I'll tell you a
little bit about what class
you might take after this one.
So brief recap of the model,
we introduced two models
of computation although one was
just a variation of the other.
The base model is an
external memory model.
This is a two-level
memory hierarchy.
CPU and cache, we view as one.
So there's instant
communication between them,
which means what
you're computing on
can involve this cache of size
m-- total size of the cache
is m-- words.
The cache is divided into
these blocks of size b each.
So they're m over b blocks.
And your problem doesn't
fit here, presumably,
or the problem's not
very interesting.
So your problem size n is
going to require storing
your information on disk.
So the input is really
provided over here.
Disk is basically
infinite in size.
It's also partitioned
into blocks.
And you can't access
individual items here.
You can only access
entire blocks.
So the model is you say,
I want to read this block
and put it here.
I want to write this
block out and put it here.
That's what you're allowed to
do in the external memory model.
And what we count is how many
block-memory transfers we do.
We call those memory transfers.
So you want to minimize that.
And usually you
don't worry too much
about what happens in here,
although you could also
minimize regular running
time as we usually do.
The cache oblivious variation
is that the algorithm is not
allowed to know the
cache parameters.
It's not allowed to
know the block size.
Sorry, it's also block
size b in the disk.
So they match.
And you're not allowed to
know the cache size, m.
Because of that, all the
block reads and writes
are done automatically.
So the model is, whenever
you access an item,
you view the disk
as just written row
by row-- sequentially
block by block.
So in linear eyes, it looks like
this, partitioned into blocks.
And so whenever
you touch an item,
the system automatically
loads that block.
If it's not already in
cache, it loads it in.
If it's already in
cache, it's free.
When you load a block
in, you probably
already have something there.
So if the cache is
already full, you
have to decide
which one to evict.
And we had a couple
of strategies.
But the one I defined was the
least-recently-used block.
So whichever one in the
cache that's least recently
been used by the
CPU, that's the one
that gets written
out, back to disk
where it originally came from.
And that's it.
That's the model.
OK, this is a pretty good
model of how real caches work.
Although this last part is
not how all real caches work.
It's close.
And at the very end, I
mentioned this theorem
that Why LRU is good.
And if you take
the number of block
evictions-- the
number of block reads,
equivalently-- then LRU has
to do on a cache of size m.
Then that's going to be,
at most, twice whatever
the best possible
thing you could do
is given a cache
of size m over 2.
So we're restricting OPT.
We're kind of tying OPT's hands
behind his back a little bit
by decreasing m
by a factor of 2.
But then we get a factor of
2 approximation, basically.
So this was the
resource augmentation.
And this is regular
approximation algorithms.
In general, this is a world
called online algorithms, which
is a whole field.
I'm just going to
mention it briefly here.
The distinction here
is LRU, or whatever
we implement in a
real system, has
to make a decision based only
on the past of what's happened.
The system, we're assuming,
doesn't know the future.
So in a compiler, maybe you
could try to predict the future
and do something.
But on a CPU, it
doesn't know what
instruction's going to come
next, 10 steps in the future.
So you just have to
make a decision now,
sort of your best guess.
And least recently used
is a good best guess.
OPT, on the other hand,
we're giving a lot of power.
This is what we call
an offline algorithm.
It's like the Q in Star
Trek: Next Generation
or some other mythical being.
It lives outside
of the timeline.
It can see all of time and say,
I think I'll evict this block.
This is like the waste
of Q's resources.
But I'll evict this
block because I
know it's going to be used
for this in the future.
LRU is evicting the thing that
was used farthest in the past.
There's a difference there.
And it could be
a big difference.
But it turns out they're
related in this way.
So this is what we call
an online algorithm,
meaning you have to make
decisions as you go.
The offline algorithm
gets to see the future
and optimize accordingly.
Both are computable, but this
one's only computable if you
know the future, which we don't.
What I haven't done
is prove this theorem.
It's actually really easy proof.
So let's do it.
I want to take the timeline
and divide it into phases.
Phases sounds cool.
So this is going
to be an analysis.
And in an analysis,
we're allowed
to know the future because
we're trying to imagine what
OPT could do relative to LRU.
So we're fixing the algorithm.
It's obviously not
using the future.
When we analyze it, we're
assuming we do know the future.
We know the entire timeline.
So all the algorithms
we covered last time,
all the ones we covered today
you can think of as just making
a sequence of accesses.
They're making sequences
of accesses to elements.
But if we assume
we know what b is,
that's just a sequence
of accesses to blocks.
OK so you can just
think of the timeline
as a sequence of block IDs.
And if you access a block that's
currently stored in cache,
it's free.
Otherwise, you pay 1.
All right, so I'm just going
to look at the timeline of all
these accesses and say, well,
take a prefix of the accesses
until I get to m over b
distinct blocks, block IDs.
Keep going until,
if I went one more,
I'd have m over b plus
1 distinct blocks.
So it's a maximal prefix of
m over b distinct blocks.
Cut there.
And then repeat.
So start over.
Start counting at zero.
Extend until I have m over
b distinct block accesses.
And if I went one more, I'd
have m over b plus 1 and so on.
So the timeline gets divided.
Who knows?
It could be totally irregular.
If you access the same
blocks many times,
you could get along for a
very long time and only access
m over b distinct blocks.
Who knows?
The algorithm
definitely doesn't know
because it doesn't know m or b.
But from an analysis
perspective,
we can just count these things.
So each of these has exactly
m over b distinct accesses,
distinct block IDs.
So I have two claims
about such a phase.
First claim is that LRU with
a cache of size m on one phase
is, at most, what?
It's easy.
STUDENT: M over b.
PROFESSOR: M over b.
The claim is, at most,
m over b basically
because the LRU
is not brain dead.
Well, you're accessing
these blocks.
And they've all been
accessed more recently.
I mean, let's look
at this phase.
All the blocks
that you touch here
have been accessed more recently
than whatever came before.
That's the definition
of this timeline.
This is an order by time.
So anything you
load in here, you
will keep preferentially
over the things that
are not in the phase because
everything in the phase
has been accessed more recently.
So maybe, eventually, you
load all m over b blocks
that are in the phase.
Everything else you touch,
by definition of a phase,
are the same blocks.
So they will remain in cache.
And that's all it
will cost, m over b
memory transfers per phase.
So this is basically ignoring
any carry over from phase
to phase.
This is a conservative
upper bounds.
But it's an upper bounds.
And then the other question
is, what could OPT do?
So OPT-- remember, we're tying
its hands behind its back.
It only has a cache
of size m over 2.
And then we're
evaluating on a phase.
I want to claim that OPT is,
well, at least half of that
if I want to get a factor of 2.
So I claim it's at
least 1/2 m over b.
Why?
Now we have to think
about carry over.
So OPT did something
in this phase.
And then we're wondering what
happens in the very next phase.
So some of these blocks may
be shared with these blocks.
We don't know.
I mean, there's
some set of blocks.
We know that this very first
block was not in the set,
otherwise the phase
would have been longer.
But maybe some
later block happens
to repeat some block
that's over there.
We don't really know.
There could be some carry over.
So how lucky could OPT be?
At this moment in
time, at the beginning
of the phase we're
looking at, it
could be the entire cache
has things that we want,
has blocks that
appear in this phase.
That's the maximum carry
over, the entire cache.
So sort of the best case for
OPT is that the entire cache
is useful, meaning it
contains blocks in the phase
that we're interested in--
the phase we're looking
at-- at the start of the phase.
That's the best case.
But because we gave up only m
over 2, that means, at most,
one half m over b blocks.
This was cache size.
This is the number of
blocks in the cache.
At most, this many
blocks will be free,
won't cost anything for OPT.
But by definition, the phase
has m over b distinct blocks.
So half of them will be free.
The other half, OPT is
going to have to load in.
So it's a kind of
trivial analysis.
It's amazing this
proof is so simple.
It's all about setting
things up right.
If you define phases
that are good for LRU,
then they're also
bad for OPT when
it has cache at half the size.
And so OPT has to pay
at least half what
LRU is definitely paying.
Here we can forget
about carry over.
Here we're bounding
the carry over just
by making the cache smaller.
That's it.
So this is a most twice that.
And so we get the theorem.
I mean, changing the cache
size could dramatically
change the number of cache
reads that you have to do
or disk reads it you
have to do into cache.
But in all of the
algorithms we will cover,
we're giving some
bound in terms of m.
That bound will
always be, at most,
some polynomial dependence in m.
Usually it's like a 1 over
m, 1 over square root of m,
1 over log m,
something like that.
All of those bounds
will only be affected
by a constant factor when you
change m by a constant factor.
So this is good enough for
cache oblivious algorithms.
All right, so that's
sort of review of why
this model is reasonable.
LRU is good.
So now we're going to talk about
two basic problems-- searching
for stuff in array, sorting an
array in both of these models.
We won't be able to
do everything cache
obliviously today.
But they're are all possible.
It just takes more
time than we have.
We'll give you more of a flavor
of how these things work.
Again, the theme is going to
be divide and conquer, my glass
class.
So let's say we have n elements.
Let's say, for simplicity,
we're in the comparison models.
So all we can really
do with those elements
is compare them-- less
than, greater than, equal.
And let's say we
want to do search
in the comparison model, which
I'll think of as a predecessor
search.
So given a new element
x, I want to find,
what is the previous element?
What's the largest element
smaller than x in my set?
I'm thinking of these n
elements as static, let's say.
You can generalize
everything I say to have
insertions and deletions.
But let's not worry
about that for now.
I just want to
store them somehow
in order to enable search.
So any suggestions in external
memory model or cache oblivious
model?
How would you do this?
[STUDENT COUGHS]
This may sound
easy, but it's not.
But that's OK.
You know, I like easy
answers, simple answers.
There's two simple answers.
One is correct, one is wrong.
But I like both, so I
want to analyze both.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Store them
sorted in order?
PROFESSOR: Store them
sorted in order, good.
That's how we'd normally
solve this problem.
So let's see how it does.
I thought I had
solution, too, here.
But that's OK.
Binary search in a sorted array,
sort the elements in order.
And then to do a query,
binary search on it.
So you remember binary search.
You've got an array.
You start in the middle.
Then let's say the element
looking for is way over here.
So then we'll go over this way
and go there, this way, there,
this way, log n time.
I mean, binary search
is, in a certain sense,
a divide and conquer algorithm.
You only recurse on one side,
but it's divide and conquer.
So divide and conquer is good.
Surely binary search is good.
If only it were that simple.
So sort of orthogonal
to this picture--
maybe I'll just draw
it on one side--
there's a division into blocks.
And in a cache
oblivious setting,
we don't know where that falls.
But the point is,
for the most part,
every one of these
accesses we do
as we go farther and farther to
the right-- almost all of them
will be in a different block.
The middle one is very far
away from the 3/4 mark.
It is very far away from
the 7/8 mark, and so on,
up until the very end.
Let's say we're
searching for the max.
So this will hold
for all of them.
At the end, once we're within
a problem of size order b,
then there's only a
constant number of blocks
that we're touching.
And so from then on, everything
will be free, basically.
So if you think
about it carefully,
the obvious upper
bound-- this is
our usual recurrence for binary
search-- would be constant.
And what we hope to gain here
is, basically, a better base
case.
And I claim that all you
get in terms of base case
here is t of b equals order 1.
And, if you think
about it, this just
solves to log n
minus log b, which
is the same thing as
log n over b, which
is a small improvement
over just regular log n
but not a big improvement.
I claim we can do better.
You've actually seen
how to do better.
But maybe we didn't tell you.
So it's a data structure you've
seen already-- b tree, yeah.
So because we weren't thinking
about this memory hierarchy
business when we
said b tree, we meant
like 2-4 trees or 5-10
trees or some constant bound
on the degree of each node.
But if you make the degree of
the node b-- or some theta b,
b approximate-- so you allow
a big branching factor.
It's got to be somewhere, let's
say, between b over 2 and b.
Then we can store all of these
pointers and all of these keys
in a constant number of blocks.
And so if we're doing just
search, as we navigate down
the b tree we'll spend
order 1 block reads
to load in this node and then
figure out which way to go.
And then let's
say it's this way.
And then we'll spend
order 1 memory transfers
to read this node then
figure out which way to go.
So the cost is going to be
proportional to the height
of the tree, which is
just log base b of n
up to the constant
factors because we're
between b over 2 and b.
But that will affect
this by a factor of 2.
So we can do search in
a b tree in the log base
b of n memory transfers.
OK, remember, log base b of
n is log n divided by log b.
So this is a lot better.
Here we had log n minus log b.
Now we have log n
divided by log b.
And this turns
out to be optimal.
In the comparison model, this
is the best you can hope to do,
so good news.
The bad news is we kind
of critically needed
to know what b was.
B trees really only make
sense if you what b is.
You need to know the
branching factor.
So this is not a cache
oblivious data structure.
But it has other nice things.
We can actually do inserts
and deletes, as well.
So I said static, but if
you want dynamic insert
and deleting elements, you
can also do those in log base
b of n memory transfers using
exactly the algorithms we've
seen with splits and merges.
So all that's good.
But I want to do it cache
obviously-- just the search
for now.
And this is not obvious.
But it's our good
friend van Emde Boas.
So despite the name, this
is not a data structure
that van Emde Boas.
But it's inspired by the data
structure that we covered.
And it's actually a solution
by Harold [INAUDIBLE],
who did the m-edge
thesis on this work.
In the conclusion, it's
like, oh, by the way,
here's how you do search.
It seems like the best
page of that thesis.
And then I think we called
it van Emde Boas because we
thought it was reminiscent.
So here's the idea.
Take all the items
you want to store.
And you're really tempted to
store them in sorted order,
but I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to use some other
divide and conquer order.
First thing I'm going to
do is take those elements,
put them in a perfectly
balanced binary search tree.
So this is a BSTT-- not a
b tree, just a binary tree
because I don't know what b is.
So then maybe the
median's up here.
And then there's two
children and so on.
OK, the mean's over here.
The max is over
here, a regular BST.
Now we know how to
search in a tree.
You just walk down.
The big question
is, in what order
should I store these nodes?
If I just store them
in a random order,
this is going to be super
bad-- log n memory transfers.
But I claim, if I
do a clever order,
I can achieve log base b
of n, which is optimal.
So van Emde Boas suggests
cutting this tree
in the middle.
Why in the middle?
This was n nodes over here.
And we're breaking it up
into a square root of n nodes
at the top because the height
of this overall tree is log n.
If we split it in half,
the height of the tree
is half log n.
2 to the half log n is root n.
I'm losing some
constant factors,
but let's just call it root n.
Then we've got, at the bottom,
everything looks the same.
We're going to have a whole
bunch of trees of size
square root of n, hopefully.
OK, that's what happens when
I cut in the middle level.
Then I recurse.
And what am I recursing?
What am I doing?
This is a layout.
Last time, we did a very
similar thing with matrices.
We had an n by n matrix.
We divided it into four n
over 2 by n over 2 matrices.
We recursively laid out the
1/4, wrote those out in order
so it was consecutive.
Then we laid out the next
quarter, next quarter,
next quarter.
The order of the
quarters didn't matter.
What mattered is that
each quarter of the matrix
was stored as a consecutive
unit so when recursed,
good things happened.
Same thing here, except now
I have roughly square root
of n plus 1.
Chunks, little
triangles-- I'm going
to recursively lay them out.
And then I'm going to
concatenate those layouts.
So this one, I'm going
to recursively figure out
what order to store those
nodes and then put those all as
consecutive in the array.
And then this one goes here.
This one goes here.
Actually, the order
doesn't matter.
But you might as well
preserve the order.
So do the top one, then
the bottom ones in order.
And so, recursively,
each of these ones
is going to get
cut in the middle.
Recursively lay out the
top, then the next one.
Let's do an example.
Let's do an actual tree.
This is actually my favorite
diagram to draw or something.
My most frequently drawn
diagram, complete binary tree
on eight children, eight leaves.
So this is 15 nodes.
It happens to have a
height that's a power of 2,
so this algorithm
works especially well.
So I'm going to
split it in half,
then recursively
lay out the top.
To lay out the top, I'm
going to split it in half.
Then I'm going to
recursively lay out the top.
Well, single node-- it's pretty
clear what order to put it
in with respect to itself.
So that goes first,
then this, then this.
Then I finish the
first recursion.
Next, I'm going to
recursively lay out this thing
by cutting it in
half, laying out
the top, then the bottom parts.
OK, then I'm going to
recursively layout this-- 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
It gets even more exciting
the next level up.
But it would take a
long time to draw this.
But just imagine this repeated.
So that would be just the
top half of some tree.
Cut here, and then you
do the same thing here
and here and here.
This is very different
from in-order traversal
or any other order
that we've seen.
This is the van Emde Boas order.
And this numbering is
supposed to be the order
that I store the nodes.
So when I write
this into memory,
it's going to look like this--
just the nodes in order.
And when I'm drawing
a circle-- wow,
this is going to get tedious.
And then there's pointers here.
Every time I draw
a circle, there's
a left pointer and
a right pointer.
So 1's going to
point to 2 and 3.
2 is going to point to 4 and 7.
So just take the regular
binary search tree,
but store it in this
really weird order.
I claim this will work really
well, log base b of n search.
Let's analyze it.
Good first time, this is
a cache oblivious layout.
I didn't use b at all.
There's no b here.
Start with a binary tree.
And I just do this recursion.
It gives me a linear
order to put the nodes in.
I'm just going to store
them in that order.
It's linear size, all that.
Now in the analysis, again,
I'm allowed to know b.
So let's say b is b.
And let's consider the
level of recursion.
Let's say the first
level of recursion,
where the triangles have less
than or equal to b nodes.
So I'm thinking of this picture.
I cut in the middle.
Then I recursively cut in
the middle of all the pieces.
Then I recursively
cut in the middle.
I started out with a
height of log n and size n.
I keep cutting, basically
square rooting the size.
At some point, when I
cut, I get triangles
that are size, at
most, square root of b.
So the tree now will
look-- actually,
let me draw a bigger picture.
Let's start down here.
So I've got triangle less
than or equal to b, triangle
less than or equal to b.
This is some attempt
to draw a general tree.
And first we cut in
the middle level.
Then we cut in
the middle levels.
And let's say, at that moment,
all of the leftover trees
have, at most, b nodes in them.
It's going to happen
at some point.
after roughly log n minus
log b levels of recursion.
The heights here will
be roughly log b.
We keep cutting in half,
still with height log b.
Then we know the size of it's b.
OK, so this is a picture
that exists in some sense.
What we know is that
each of these triangles
is stored consecutively.
By this recursive
layout, we guarantee
that, at any level of
recursion, each chunk
is stored consecutively.
So, in particular, this
level-- level b-- is nice.
So what that tells us is that
each triangle with, at most, b
elements is
consecutive, which means
it occupies at most two blocks.
If we're lucky, it's one.
But if we're unlucky in
terms of-- here's memory.
Here's how it's
split into blocks.
Maybe it's consecutive, but
it crosses a block boundary.
But the distance between
these two lines is b and b.
And the length of
the blue thing is b.
So you can only cross one line.
So you fit in two blocks.
Each of these triangles
fits in two blocks.
Now, let's think about
search algorithm.
We're going to do regular binary
search in a binary search tree.
We start at the root.
We compare to x.
We go left to right.
Then we go left to
right, left to right.
Eventually we find the
predecessor or the successor
or, ideally, the element
we're actually searching for.
And so what we're
doing is following
some root-to-node
path in the tree.
Maybe we stop early.
In the worst case,
we go down to a leaf.
But it's a vertical path.
You only go down.
Over here, same thing.
Let's say, because these
are the ones I drew,
you go here somewhere.
But in general, you're following
some root-to-node path.
And you're visiting some
sequence of triangles.
Each triangle fits in,
basically, one block.
Let's assume, as usual,
m over b is at least two.
So you can store at
least two blocks,
which means, once you
start touching a triangle,
all further touches are free.
The first one, you have
to pay the load in,
maybe these two blocks.
Every subsequent touch as you
go down this path is free.
Then you go to a new triangle.
That could be somewhere
completely different.
We don't really now, but
it's some other two blocks.
And as long as you stay within
the triangle, it's free.
So the cost is going to be,
at most, twice the number
of triangles that you visit.
MTN is going to be, at
most, twice the number
of triangles visited
by a root-to-node path,
a downward path in the
binary search tree.
OK, now to figure
that out we need not
only an upper bound on how
big the triangles are but also
a lower bound.
I said the height of
the tree is about log b.
It's close.
Maybe you have
triangles of size b
plus 1, which is a
little bit too big.
So let's think about that case.
You have b plus 1 nodes.
And then you end up cutting
in the middle level.
So before, you had a height of
almost log b-- slightly more
than log b.
Then, when you cut it
in half, the new heights
will be half log b.
And then you'll have
only square root
of b items in the triangle.
So that may seem problematic.
These things are, at most, b.
They're also at
least square root b.
The height of a
triangle at this level
is somewhere between
half log b and log b.
Basically, we're binary
searching on height.
We're stopping when
we divide it by 2.
And we get something less
than log B in height.
Luckily, we only
care about heights.
We don't care that there's
only root b items here.
That may seem inefficient, but
because everything's in a log
here-- because we
only care about
log b in the running time, and
we're basically approximating
log b within a factor
of 2-- everything's
going to work up to
constant factors.
In other words, if
you look at this path,
we know the length
of the path is log n.
We know the height of
each of these triangles
is at least half log b.
That means the number
of triangles you visit
is log n divided by half log b.
And the length of
the path is log n.
So the number of triangles on
the path is, at most, log n
divided by how much progress we
make for each triangle, which
is half log b-- also known
as 2 times log base b of n.
And then we get the
number of memory transfers
is, at most, twice that.
So the number of memory
transfers is going to be,
at most, 4 times
log base b of n.
And that's order log base
b of n, which is optimal.
Now we don't need to know b.
How's that for a cheat?
So we get optimal running time,
except for the constant factor.
Admittedly, this is not perfect.
B trees get basically 1
times log base b of n.
This cache oblivious binary
search gives you 4 times
log base b of n.
But this was a rough analysis.
You can actually get that
down to like 1.4 times
log base b of n.
And that's tight.
So you can't do quite
as well with cache
oblivious as external
memory but close.
And that's sort
of the story here.
If you ignore constant
factors, all is good.
In practice, where
you potentially
win is that, if you designed
a b tree for specific b,
you're going to do really great
for that level of the memory
hierarchy.
But in reality, there's many
levels to the memory hierarchy.
They all matter.
Cache oblivious is
going to win a lot
because it's optimal at
all levels simultaneously.
It's really hard to
build a b tree that's
optimal for many values
of b simultaneously.
OK so that is search.
Any questions before
we go on to source?
[STUDENTS COUGHING]
One obvious question
is, what about dynamic?
Again, I said static.
Obviously the elements
aren't changing here.
Just doing search
in log base b of n,
it turns out you can do insert,
delete, and search in log base
b of n memory transfers
per operation.
This was my first result
in cache oblivious land.
It's when I met Charles
Leiserson, actually.
But I'm not going to cover it.
If you want to know how, you
should take 6851, Advanced Data
Structures, which talks about
all sorts of things like this
but dynamic.
It turns out there's a lot more
to say about this universe.
And I want to go in to sorting
instead of talking about how
to make that dynamic because,
oh, OK, search log base
b of n, that was optimal.
I said, oh, you can also do
insert and delete in log base
b of n.
It turns out that's not optimal.
It's as good as b trees.
But you can do better.
B trees are not good at updates.
And if you've ever worked with
a database, you may know this.
If you have a lot of updates,
b trees are really slow.
They're good for searches,
not good for updates.
You can do a lot better.
And that will be
exhibited by sorting.
So sorting-- I think
you know the problem.
You're given n elements in an
array in some arbitrary order.
You want to put them
into sorted order.
Or, equivalently, you want to
put them into a van Emde Boas
order.
Once their sorted, it's
not too hard to transfer
into this order.
So you can do search
fast or whatever.
Sorting is a very basic
thing we like to do.
And the obvious way
to sort when you have,
basically, a-- let's pretend
we have this b tree data
structure, cache oblivious even.
Or we just use regular b trees.
Let's use regular b trees.
Forget about cache oblivious.
External memory, we
know how to do b trees.
We know how to
insert into a b tree.
So the obvious way to sort is to
do n inserts into, if you want,
a cache oblivious b tree
or just a regular b tree.
How long does that take?
N times log base b of n.
It sounds OK.
But it's not optimal.
It's actually really slow
compared to what you can do.
You can do, roughly,
a factor of b faster.
But it's the best we
know how to do so far.
So the goal is to do better.
And, basically, what's going
on is we can do inserts.
In this universe, we can
do inserts and deletes
faster than we can do searches,
which is a little weird.
It will become clearer
as we go through.
So what's another
natural way to sort?
What means to sorting
algorithm that we've
covered are optimal in
the comparison model?
STUDENT: Merge sort.
PROFESSOR: Merge sort,
that's a good one.
We could do quick
sort, too, I guess.
I'll stick to merge sort.
Merge sort's nice because
A, it's divide and conquer.
And we like divide and conquer.
It seems to work,
if we do it right.
And it's also cache oblivious.
There's no b in merge sort.
We didn't even know what b was.
So great, merge sort
is divide and conquer
and cache oblivious.
So how much does it cost?
Well, let's think
about merge sort.
You take an array.
You divide it in half.
That takes zero time.
That's just a conceptual thing.
You recursively sort this part.
That looks good because
those items are consecutive.
So that recursion is going
to be an honest to goodness
recursion on an array.
So we can write a recurrence.
And then we have to
merge the two parts.
So in merge, we take the
first element of each guy.
We compare them,
output one of them,
advance that one, compare,
advance that guy.
That's three parallel scans.
We're scanning in this array.
We're always advancing
forward, which
means as long as we
store the first block
of this guy and the first
block of this guy who
knows how it's aligned--
But we'll read these
items one by one
until we finish that block.
Then we'll just read the next
block, read those one by one.
And similarly for
the output array,
we first start filling a block.
Once it's filled, we
can kick that one out
and read the next one.
As long as m over
b is at least 3,
we can afford this
three-parallel scan.
It's not really parallel.
It's more like inter-leaf scans.
But we're basically
scanning in here
while we're also
and scanning in
the output array.
And we can merge
two sorted arrays
into a new sorted array in
scan time, n over be plus 1.
So that means the number
of memory transfers
is 2 times the number of memory
transfers for half the size,
like regular merge sort,
plus n over b plus 1.
That's our recurrence.
Now we just need to solve it.
Well, before we solve
it, in this case
we always have to be
careful with the base case.
Base case is MT of m.
This is the best base
case we could use.
Let's use it.
When I reach an array of size
m, I read the whole thing.
And then that's all I can pay.
So I won't incur any
more cost as long
as I stay within that
region of size m.
Maybe I should put
some constant times m
because this is not in
place algorithm, so maybe
1/3 m something.
As long as I'm not too
close to the cache size,
I will only pay m over
b memory transfers.
So far so good.
Now we just solve
the recurrence.
This is a nice recurrence,
very similar to
the old merge-sort recurrence.
We just have a different
thing in the additive term.
And we have a
different base case.
The way I like to
solve nice recurrences
is with recursion trees.
This is actually a trick I
learned by teaching this class.
Before this, cache oblivious
was really painful to me
because I could never
solve the currencies.
Then I thought the class and
was like, oh, this is easy.
I hope the same
transformation happens to you.
You'll see how easy it is
once we do this example.
OK, this is merge sort.
Remember recursion
tree, in every node
you put the additive cost
so that, if you added up
the cost of all of
these nodes, you
would get the total
value of this expands
to because we're
basically making
two children of size n over 2.
And then we're
putting, at the root,
this cost, which means, if
you add up all of these nodes,
you're getting all
of these costs.
And that's the total cost.
So it's n over b at the top.
Then it's going to be n over
2 divided by b and so on.
I'm omitting the plus
1 just for cleanliness.
You'd actually have to count.
And this keeps going until
we hit the base case.
This is where
things are a little
different from
regular merge sort,
other than the divided by b.
We stop when we reach
something at size m.
So at the leaf level,
we have something
of size m, which
means we basically
have m over b in each leaf.
And then we should think about
how many leaves there are.
This is just n over
m leaves, I guess.
There's lots of
ways to see that.
One way to think about it
is we're conserving mass.
We started with n items.
Split it in half,
split it in half.
So the number of items
is remaining fixed.
Then at the bottom
we have m items.
And so the number of leaves
has to be exactly n over m
because the total should be n.
You can also think of it as
2 to the power log of that.
We have, usually, log n levels.
But we're cutting off
a log m at the bottom.
So it's log n minus
log m as the height.
I'll actually need that.
The height of this tree is
log n minus log m, also known
as log n/m.
OK, so we've drawn this tree.
Now, what we usually do
is add up level by level.
That usually gives
a very clean answer.
So we add up the top level.
That's n over b.
We add up the second level.
That's n over b, by
conservation of mass
again and because this
was a linear function.
So each level, in fact, is going
to be exactly n over b cost.
We should be a little
careful about the bottom
because the base
case-- I mean, it
happens that the base
case matches this.
But it's always good practice
to think about the leaf level
separately.
But the leaf level is just
m over b times n over m
The m's cancel, so m
over b times n over m.
This is n over b.
So every level is n over b.
The number of levels
is log of n over m.
Cool.
So the number of
memory transfers
is just the product
of those two things.
It's n over b times
that log, log n over m.
Now let's compare.
That's sorting.
Over here, we had a running
time of n times log base b of n.
So this is n log n
divided by log b.
Log base b is the same
as dividing by log b.
So n log n divided by log--
we had regular sorting time.
And then we divided by log b.
Over here, we have basically
regular sorting time.
But now we're dividing by b.
That's a huge improvement-- a
b divided by log b improvement.
I mean, think of the b
being like a million.
So before we were dividing
by 20, which is OK.
But now we're
dividing by a million.
That's better.
So this way of sorting
is so much better
than this way of sorting.
It's still not optimal,
but we're getting better.
We can actually get sort of the
best of both worlds-- divide
by b and divide
by log b, I claim.
But we need a new algorithm.
Any suggestions for
another algorithm?
STUDENT: Divide
into block size b.
PROFESSOR: I want to
divide into block size b.
So, you mean a merge sort?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So merge
sort, I take my array.
I divide it into
blocks the size b.
I could sort each one
in one memory transfer.
And then I need to merge them.
So then I've got n divided
by b sorted arrays.
I don't know how to merge them.
It's going to be
hard, but very close.
So the answer is
indeed merge sort.
What we covered before
is binary merge sort.
You split into two groups.
What I want to do now is
split into some other number
of groups.
So that was n over b groups.
That's too many because merging
n over b arrays is hard.
Merging two arrays was easy.
Assuming m over
b was at least 3,
I could merge these guys
just by parallel scans.
So you have the right bound?
STUDENT: B way.
PROFESSOR: B way, maybe.
STUDENT: Square root of b.
PROFESSOR: Square root of b?
That's what I like
to call root beer.
[LAUGHTER]
Nope.
I do call it that.
Yeah?
STUDENT: M over b?
PROFESSOR: M over b, that's
what I'm looking for!
Why m over b?
STUDENT: I was just
thinking of the bottom layer
of the [INAUDIBLE]
binary merge sort.
PROFESSOR: Because
m over b is up here?
Nice.
[LAUGHTER]
Not the right reason, but
you get a Frisbee anyway.
All right, let's see
if I can do this.
Would you like another one?
Add to your collection.
All right, so m over b is the
right answer-- wrong reason,
but that's OK.
It all comes down
to this merge step.
So m over b way means I
take my problem of size n.
Let's draw it out.
I divide into chunks.
I want the number of
chunks that I divide into
to be m over b, meaning each of
these has size n over m over b.
That's weird.
This is natural because
this is how many blocks
I can have in cache.
I care about that because, if
I want to do a multi-way merge,
you can mimic the
same binary merge.
You look at the first item
of each of the sorted arrays.
You compare them.
In this model,
comparisons are free.
Let's not even worry about it.
In reality, use a priority
queue, but all right.
So you find the
minimum of these.
Let's say it's this one.
And you output that,
and then you advance.
Same algorithm, that will merge
however many arrays you have.
The issue is, for this to be
efficient like it was here,
we need to be able to store
the first block of each
of these arrays.
How many blocks
we have room for?
M over b.
This is maxing out merge sort.
This is exactly the number
of blocks that we can store.
And so if we do m over
b way merge sort, merge
remains cheap.
An m over b way merge
costs n over b plus 1,
just like before.
It's m over b parallel scans.
M over b is exactly the
number of scans we can handle.
OK, technically we
have, with this picture,
m over b plus 1 scans.
So I need to write
m over b minus 1.
But it won't make a difference.
OK, so let's write
down the recurrence.
It's pretty similar.
Memory transfer's size m.
We have m over b sub problems
of size n divided by m over b.
It's Still conservation of mass.
And then we have plus
the same thing as before,
n over b plus 1.
So it's exactly the same
recurrence we had before.
We're splitting
into more problems.
But the sums are
going to be the same.
It's still going to add up
to n over b at each step
because conservation of mass.
And we didn't change this.
So level by level
looks the same.
The only thing that changes
is the number of levels.
Now we're taking n.
We're dividing by m
over b in each step.
So the height of
the tree, the number
of levels of the
recursion tree now
is-- before it was log
base 2 of n over n.
Now it's going to be log
base m over b of n over m.
If you're careful,
I guess there's
a plus 1 for the leaf level.
I actually want to
mention this plus 1.
Unlike the other
plus 1's, I've got
to mention this one because
this is not how I usually
think of the number of levels.
I'll show you why.
If you just change
it by one, you
get a slightly cleaner formula.
This has got m's
all over the place.
So I just want to
rewrite n over m here.
Then we'll see how good this is.
This is just pedantics.
Log base m over b of n--
I really want n over b.
To make this n over b, I need
to multiply by b, divide by m.
OK, these are the same thing.
M over m, b's cancel.
But I have a log of a product.
I can separate that out.
Let's go over here.
This is log base m over b of n
over b-- this is what I like--
and then, basically, minus
log base m over b of m over b.
STUDENT: It's b over m.
PROFESSOR: I put a
minus, so it's m over b.
If I put a plus, it
would be b over m.
But, in fact, m
is bigger than b.
So I want it this way.
And now it's obvious this is 1.
So these cancel.
So that's why I wanted the
1, just to get rid of that.
It doesn't really
matter, just a plus 1.
But it's a cooler way to
see that, in some sense,
this is the right answer
of the height of the tree.
Now, we're paying n over
b at each recursive level.
So the total cost is what's
called the sorting bound.
This is optimal, n over b times
log base m over b of n over b.
Oh my gosh, what a mouthful.
But every person who does
external memory algorithms
and cache oblivious
algorithms knows this.
It is the truth, it turns out.
There's a matching lower bound.
It's a weird bound.
But let's compare
it to what we know.
So we started out with n
log n divided by log b.
Then we got n log
n divided by b.
Let's ignore-- I mean,
this has almost no effect,
the part in here.
Now we have n log n divided by
b and divided by log m over b.
It's not quite
dividing by log b.
But it turns out it's
almost always the same.
In some sense, this
could be better.
If you're cache is big, now
you're dividing by log m,
roughly.
Before, you were only
dividing by log b.
And it turns out this
is the best you can do.
So this is going to be a little
bit better than merge sort.
If your cache is 16 gigabytes,
like your RAM caching
your disk, then log
m is pretty big.
It's going to be 32 or
something, 34 I guess log m.
OK, I have to divide by b.
So it's not that good.
But still, I'm getting an
improvement over regular binary
merge sort.
And you would see
that improvement.
These are big factors.
The big thing, of course,
is dividing it by b.
But dividing by log of m over
b is also nice and the best you
can do.
OK, obviously I needed to
know what m and b were here.
So the natural question next
is cache oblivious sorting.
And that would take
another lecture to cover.
So I'm not going to do it here.
But it can be done.
Cache obliviously, you can
achieve the same thing.
And I'll give you the intuition.
There's one catch.
Let me mention the catch.
So cache oblivious sorting--
to do optimal cache oblivious
sorting like that
bound, it turns out you
need an assumption called
the tall-cache assumption.
Simple form of the
tall-cache assumption
is that m is at least b squared.
What that means is m
over b is at least b.
In other words, the cache
is taller than it is wide,
the way I've been drawing it.
That's why it's called
the tall-cache assumption.
And if you look at real caches,
this is usually the case.
I don't know of a great reason
why it should be the case.
But it usually is,
so all is well.
You can do cache
oblivious sorting.
It turns out, if you don't
have this assumption,
you cannot achieve this bound.
We don't know what
bound you can achieve.
But we just know this
one is not possible.
You can get a contradiction
if you achieve that
without tall cache.
So it's a little bit weird.
You have to make one
bonus assumption.
You can make a somewhat
weaker form of it,
which is m is omega
b to the 1.000000001.
That will do.
In general, 1 plus epsilon.
Any epsilon will be fine.
We just mean that
the number of blocks
is at least some
b to the epsilon,
where epsilon's a
constant bigger than zero.
OK, then you can do
cache oblivious sorting.
Let me tell you how.
We want to do m over
b way merge sort.
But we don't know how to do--
we don't know what m over b is.
So instead, we're going
to do something like n
to the epsilon way merge sort.
That's a so-so interpretation.
This is back to
your idea roughly.
We're dividing into
a lot of chunks.
And then we don't know
how to merge them anymore
because we can't do regular
merge with n to the epsilon
chunks it could be n to
the epsilon's too big.
So how do we do it?
We do a divide
and conquer merge.
This is actually
called funnel sort
because the way you do a
divide and conquer merge looks
kind of like a funnel.
Actually, it looks a
lot like the triangles
we were drawing earlier.
It's just a lot
messier to analyze.
So I'm not going to do it here.
It would take another
40 minutes or so.
But that's some intuition of
how you do cache oblivious
merge sort.
That's what I want to say
cache oblivious stuff.
Oh, one more thing!
One more cool thing you can
do-- I'm a data structures guy.
So sorting is nice.
But what I really like
are priority queues
because they're more
general than sorting.
We started out by
saying, hey, look.
If you want to sort
and you use a b tree,
you get a really
bad running time.
That's weird because
usually BST sort
is good in a regular
comparison model.
It's n log n.
So b trees are clearly
not what we want.
Is there some other
thing we want?
And it turns out, yes.
You can build a
priority queue, which
supports insert and
delete min and a bunch
of other operations.
Each of those operations costs
1 over b log base m over b of n
over b amortized memory
transfers-- a bit of a mouthful
again.
But if you compare this
bound with this bound,
it's exactly the same.
But I divided by n, which means
if I insert with this cost n
times, I pay the sorting bound.
If I delete min with
this bound n times,
I get the sorting bound.
So if I insert n times and
then delete all the items out,
I've sorted the items
in sorting bound time.
So this is the data
structure generalization
of that sorting algorithm.
Now, this is even harder to do.
Originally, it was
done external memory.
It's called buffer trees.
Then we did it
cache obliviously.
It's called cache
oblivious priority queues.
We weren't very creative.
But it can be done.
And, again, if you
want to learn more,
you should take 6851,
Advanced Data Structures,
which leads us into
the next topic, what
class you should take
next-- classes, that's
what I mean to say.
So a lot of bias here.
And well I'm just going
to give a lot of classes.
There's a lot of them.
I believe this is in roughly
numerical order almost.
It changed a little
bit-- so many classes.
Are you OK with numbers,
or do you want titles?
The obvious follow-on
course to this class
is 6854, which is
Advanced Algorithms.
It's the first graduate
algorithms class.
This is the last undergraduate
class, roughly speaking,
with the exception of 6047.
But in terms of straight,
general algorithms,
this would be the natural class.
It's only in the fall--
sadly, not next fall.
But in general,
it's a cool class.
It's a very broad overview of
algorithms but much more hard
core, I guess.
It's an intense class but
covers a lot of fields,
a lot of areas of algorithms.
Then all the other
ones I'm going to list
are more specialized.
So 6047 is
Computational Biology.
So if you're
interested in biology,
you want algorithms
applied to biology.
That's a cool class.
It's also an undergrad class.
Everything else here-- I
mean, you know the story.
You take grad
classes all the time,
or you will soon if you
want to do more algorithms.
So 6850 is
computational geometry.
I think it's called
Geometric Algorithms.
So we've seen a
couple examples, like
the convex hull
divide-and-conquer
algorithm and the range trees.
Those are two examples
of geometric algorithms
where you have points and
lines and stuff-- maybe
in two dimensions, maybe
in three dimensions,
maybe log n dimensions.
If you like that
stuff, you should
take computational geometry.
This is the devil that
lad me into algorithms
in the first place.
Cool stuff.
6849 is my class on
folding algorithms.
This is a special type
of geometric algorithms
where we think about paper
folding and robotic arm folding
and protein folding
and things like that.
So that's a bit of
a specialized class.
6851, I've mentioned three times
now-- Advanced Data Structures.
Then we've got
6852, its neighbor.
This is Nancy's Distributed
Algorithms class.
So if you liked the week
of distributed algorithms,
there's a whole class on it.
She wrote the textbook for it.
Then there's 6853.
This is Algorithmic Game Theory.
If you care about
algorithms involving
multiple players-- and the
players are each selfish.
And they have no reason
to tell you the truth.
And still you want
to compute something
like minimum spanning tree,
or pick your favorite thing.
Everyone's lying about
the edge weights.
And still you want
to figure out how
to design a mechanism
like an auction
so that you actually end up
buying a minimum spanning tree.
You can do that.
And if you want to know
how, you should take 6853.
What else do we have?
6855 is Network Optimization.
So this is like the natural
follow on of network flows.
If you like network flows
and things like that,
there's a whole universe
called network optimization.
It has lots of fancy,
basically, graph algorithms
where you're minimizing
or maximizing something.
OK, this is
fortuitous alignment.
6856 is kind of
a friend of 6854.
These are both taught
by David Carter.
This is Randomized Algorithms.
So this is a more
specialized approach.
I don't think you need
one to take the other.
But this is the
usual starting class.
And this is specifically
about how randomization makes
algorithms faster or simpler.
Usually they're
harder to analyze.
But you get very simple
algorithms that run just
as well as their
deterministic versions.
Sometimes you can
do even better than
the deterministic versions.
Then there's the
security universe.
This is a great
numerical coincidence--
probably not a coincidence.
But there's 6857 and 6875.
I have to remember
which is which.
6857 is Applied Cryptography.
6875 is Theoretical
Cryptography,
at least as I read it.
So they have similar topics.
But this is more thinking
about how you really
achieve security and crypto
systems and things like that.
And this one is more
algorithm based.
And what kind of
theoretical assumptions
do you need to prove
certain things?
This is more proof based.
And this is more connecting
to systems, both great topics.
And I have one
more out of order,
I guess just because
it's a recent addition.
6816 is Multicore Programming.
That has a lot of
algorithms, too.
And this is all about
parallel computation.
When you have multiple
cores on your computer,
how can you compute
things like these things
faster than
everything we've done?
It's yet another universe
that we haven't even
touched on in this class.
But it's cool stuff, and
you might consider it.
Then we move on to
other theory classes.
That was algorithms.
Some more obvious candidates,
if you like pure theory,
are 6045 6840.
This is the undergrad version.
This is the grad version.
Although, by now the
classes are quite different.
So they cover different things.
Some of you are
already taking 6045.
It's right before this lecture.
These are general theory of
computation classes, atomita,
complexity, things like that.
If you like the brief
NP completeness lecture,
then you might like this stuff.
There's so many more complexity
classes and other cool things
you can do.
If you really like it, there's
advanced complexity theory.
There's, basically,
randomized complexity theory--
how randomness affects
just the complexity side,
not algorithms.
Then there's quantum
complexity theory
if you care about
quantum computers.
As Scott says,
it's proving things
you can't do with
computers we don't have.
[LAUGHTER]
It's complexity.
It's all about lower bounds.
And then there's coding theory,
which is another universe.
It's actually closely
related to-- it comes out
of signals and systems and
electrical engineering.
But by now it's closely
related to complexity theory.
You can use bounds on
codes to prove things
about complexity theory.
Anyway, choose
your own adventure.
Now I have one last topic,
which was not on the outline.
This is a bit of a surprise.
It's a boring surprise.
I want to remind you to fill
out student evaluations.
[LAUGHTER]
Because, you know, we
want to know how we did
and how we can continue
to improve the class.
But really we want to know
who's the better teacher.
But more importantly than
who is the better teacher,
I think we all have a dying
question, which is who
is the better Frisbee thrower?
So I want to invite Srini
Devadas, our co-lecturer here,
to a duel.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
SRINI DEVADAS: I think
you mean, no contest.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Not so sure.
Maybe-- actually,
I'm pretty sure.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to take you on, man.
Blue or purple?
SRINI DEVADAS: Blue.
PROFESSOR: Good choice.
SRINI DEVADAS: Blue's
better, remember?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Purple's
better, remember?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so how are
we going to do this?
SRINI DEVADAS: So, you
guys get to cheer and bet.
PROFESSOR: Bet?
I don't think we can
condone them betting money.
I think maybe they can
bet their Frisbees.
Anyone got a Frisbee on them?
We can bet those.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, all right.
PROFESSOR: All right, maybe not.
SRINI DEVADAS: Put your
Frisbees on me here.
PROFESSOR: All right.
SRINI DEVADAS: All right,
so some rules here--
we actually talked about this.
So the way this is
going to work-- I mean,
it's going to be
algorithmic, obviously.
And we get to choose
our algorithm, maybe
with a little game theory here.
We're going to toss the coin.
And we're going to
decide who goes first.
So won't spin the Frisbee.
Remember what
happened with that?
So you get to call heads or
tails while it's spinning.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
while it's spinning.
SRINI DEVADAS:
While it's spinning.
This is our Super Bowl.
PROFESSOR: Heads!
Oh, a trick.
Tails.
SRINI DEVADAS: Tails, all right.
You're going to throw first.
PROFESSOR: OK,
that's your choice.
SRINI DEVADAS: And I
don't know if you've heard
the legend of William Tell.
How many of you have heard
the legend of William Tell?
All right.
So that was a 14th
century Swiss legend
where there was this archer
who was renowned for his skill.
And he was forced by
this villainous king
to shoot an apple off the
top of his son's head.
PROFESSOR: Yikes.
SRINI DEVADAS: So we're
going to reenact that.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Did you
bring your daughter?
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
SRINI DEVADAS: I
was thinking TAs.
PROFESSOR: Our "sons."
SRINI DEVADAS: But
there's a big difference
between the 21st century
and the 14th century.
What is that?
STUDENT: You get sued.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: You get sued, yeah.
SRINI DEVADAS: Now
there's many more lawsuits
in the 21st century.
So we want to avoid lawsuits.
STUDENT: Genetically
modified apples.
PROFESSOR: And genetically
modified apples, also.
SRINI DEVADAS: Electronically
modified Apples,
yeah that's going to
be another difference.
So we decided we'd just
throw Frisbees at each other.
PROFESSOR: So I'm
going to throw to you
and try to hit an
apple off of your head.
SRINI DEVADAS:
Yeah, well you might
want to tell them what we
decided about the apple.
PROFESSOR: Well, I brought
an easy-to-hit apple,
a nice big apple,
the cowboy hat.
SRINI DEVADAS: Cowboy hat.
PROFESSOR: That should
be a little easier.
SRINI DEVADAS: So I get to wear
that had first because you're
going to throw first.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SRINI DEVADAS: And this
is really simple, guys.
Knock the hat off, I guess from
the furthest distance, and win.
In your case, lose but yeah.
PROFESSOR: Now for the PETA
people in the audience,
I want your assure
no humans will
be harmed during this
performance, only professors.
[LAUGHTER]
And maybe egos, pride.
SRINI DEVADAS: Seven.
I think seven is a good number.
PROFESSOR: Seven for--
SRINI DEVADAS: You get to--
PROFESSOR: I'm going
to grab purple.
SRINI DEVADAS: You get to pick.
You can stand right here.
That's probably
what's good for you.
[LAUGHTER]
Or you can go all
the way up there.
And after you
knock this hat off,
I'm going to have to match you.
PROFESSOR: All right.
SRINI DEVADAS: So
furthest away wins.
PROFESSOR: I think I'll
try from about here.
SRINI DEVADAS: Right.
Ah!
I've got to look good here, man.
PROFESSOR: I have to
do it without looking.
SRINI DEVADAS: I'm going
to stand right here.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SRINI DEVADAS: OK.
Ah!
[LAUGHTER]
I've got to gear up for this.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SRINI DEVADAS: Look, I
know how well you throw.
PROFESSOR: Are you scared?
That's embarrassing.
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah!
I can't deal with this.
I just have no confidence
in the way you throw.
So I borrowed this.
[LAUGHTER]
Since this is mine,
it's going to cost you
a throw to wear this.
PROFESSOR: Hey!
SRINI DEVADAS: No, all right.
Whatever, fair.
All right.
Now I'm feeling much
better about this.
I won't claim to
have a pretty face.
But I like it just the way
it is, just the way it is.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Well, since we have a
little more protection,
maybe I'll start
from farther back.
SRINI DEVADAS: All right.
I think I'll hold this
up here like that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I just have to hit
the hat off, right?
Easy.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yup.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: You can keep that.
Oh right, so I'm
going to get closer.
One step closer.
Luckily, my steps are much
bigger than your steps.
OK, throw 2.
[LAUGHTER]
Throw three.
Throw four.
SRINI DEVADAS: That
didn't even hurt.
Come on, man!
Throw a little harder here!
PROFESSOR: Oh!
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SRINI DEVADAS: All
right, mark it.
PROFESSOR: All right,
I marked my spot.
SRINI DEVADAS: You've got
a couple more throws here
to do better.
PROFESSOR: More throws?
SRINI DEVADAS:
You can do better.
PROFESSOR: Wait, to go back.
SRINI DEVADAS: You've
got a couple more, yeah.
PROFESSOR: You almost hit me.
[LAUGHTER]
[GROANING]
I'm getting better!
Not much-- can I go back now?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, sure.
PROFESSOR: I don't
know the rules.
[APPLAUSE]
SRINI DEVADAS: Goodness.
PROFESSOR: No contest, right?
SRINI DEVADAS: I'm getting
a little worried here.
PROFESSOR: One more Frisbee.
Two more Frisbees.
Hey, that was your Frisbee.
SRINI DEVADAS: One more.
All right.
PROFESSOR: I think we've
done binary search here.
[APPLAUSE]
SRINI DEVADAS: You need this.
And you don't really need
this, but I'll give it to you.
PROFESSOR: So much confidence.
Well, I have so much
confidence in you
I brought some extra Frisbees.
[LAUGHTER]
SRINI DEVADAS: I get to
use all of them, huh?
PROFESSOR: You need it, man.
SRINI DEVADAS: All right.
No, we're going to be fair.
You threw seven.
I'm going to throw seven.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
You've got a bit
of a big head here.
PROFESSOR: Do this.
All right, so I put
the hat on the head.
OK.
Where were you
standing, by the way?
Way back here, right?
SRINI DEVADAS: No, nope.
I was right there.
PROFESSOR: OK.
SRINI DEVADAS: Right there.
PROFESSOR: All
right, right here.
Can I hold onto the hat?
SRINI DEVADAS: No!
You can hold on to your helmet!
PROFESSOR: All right.
SRINI DEVADAS: Wow.
PROFESSOR: Ah!
[LAUGHTER]
How many throws--
SRINI DEVADAS: Maybe I
should start from right here.
[GROANING]
PROFESSOR: Phew.
That was close.
SRINI DEVADAS: Oh, I grazed it!
But it's supposed to fall off.
PROFESSOR: What, my head?
[LAUGHTER]
SRINI DEVADAS: Getting
kind of tight here, guys.
Wow.
[YELLING AND GROANING]
Does that count?
STUDENT: No!
SRINI DEVADAS: It does count.
SRINI DEVADAS: It's a tie.
So far, it's a tie.
So far, it's a tie!
All right, if I
knock it off, I win.
[LAUGHTER]
[GROANING]
There you you.
PROFESSOR: Is that it?
[APPLAUSE]
SRINI DEVADAS: This
was fair and square.
We want the world to
know that we did not
deflate these Frisbees.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So not only did we do a bad
job of throwing Frisbee to you
guys, we didn't throw enough
Frisbees, as you can see,
through the term.
So if you want a
Frisbee, pick one up.
And if you're embarrassed
about throwing Frisbees
with this lettering on
it, I've got two words
for you-- paint remover.
All right, have a good summer.
And have fun on the final exam.
[APPLAUSE]